in the last couple videos i've been
talking about curl where if we have a
two-dimensional vector field v defined
with component functions p and q i've
said that the 2d curl of that function v
gives you a new function that also takes
in x and y as inputs and its formula is
the partial derivative of q with respect
to x minus the partial derivative of p
with respect to y and my hope is that
this is more than just a formula and you
can understand how this represents fluid
rotation in two dimensions but what i
want to do here is show how the original
intuition i gave for this formula might
be a little oversimplified because for
example if we look at this the partial q
partial x component i said that you can
imagine that q at some point starting
off a little bit negative so the y
component of the output is a little
negative then as you move positively in
the x direction it goes to being zero
and then it goes to being a little bit
positive and with this particular
picture it's hopefully a little bit
clear why this can correspond to
counterclockwise rotation in the fluid
but this is only a very specific
circumstance for what partial q partial
x being positive could look like you
know it might also look like
q starting off a little bit positive and
then as you move in the x direction it
becomes even more positive and then even
more positive and according to the
formula this should contribute as much
to positive curl as this very clear-cut
kind of whirlpool example
and to illustrate what this might look
like if we take a look at this vector
field here
if we look in the center this is kind of
the clear-cut whirlpool
counter-clockwise rotation example
and if we play the fluid flow the fluid
does indeed rotate counter-clockwise in
the region but contrast that with what
goes on over here on the right
this doesn't look like rotation in that
sense at all instead the fluid particles
are just kind of rushing up through it
but in fact the curl in this region is
going to be just as strong as it is over
here and i'll show that with the formula
and kind of computing it through in just
a moment but the the image that you
might have in your mind is to imagine a
paddle wheel of sorts where let's say
it's got arms kind of like that and then
you hold down with your thumb that
middle portion so even though the paddle
wheel left to its own devices would just
kind of fly up i want to say let's say
you're holding that down with your thumb
but it's free to rotate
then the vectors on its left are
pointing up but less strongly than the
vectors on its right which are even
greater so if you if you imagine that
set up and you kind of have your paddle
wheel there then when you play the fluid
rotation holding your thumb down but
letting the paddle wheel rotate freely
it's also going to rotate just as it
would over here in the easier to see
whirlpool example
and in terms of the formula
this is because a situation like this
one here where q goes from being
negative to zero to positive should be
treated just the same as a situation
like this as far as 2d curl is concerned
because this term in the 2d curl formula
is going to come out the same for either
one of these and it's worth pointing out
by the way curl isn't something that
mathematicians and physicists came
across trying to understand fluid flow
instead they found this term as being
significant in various other formulas
and circumstances and i think
electromagnetism might be where it
originally came about
but then in trying to understand this
formula they realize that you can give a
fluid flow interpretation that gives a
very deep understanding of what's going
on beyond just the symbols themselves so
let me let me go ahead and walk through
this example in terms of the formula
representing the vector field it's a
relatively straightforward formula
actually
so p and q
that x component is going to be negative
y and the y component q is equal to x
so when we apply our 2d curl formula and
play the partial of q with respect to x
so partial of this second component with
respect to x is just one
and then we subtract off the partial of
p with respect to y
which up here is negative 1 because p is
just equal to negative y
so the 2d curl is equal to 2 and in
particular it's a constant 2 that
doesn't depend on x and y which is
pretty unusual most times that you apply
2d curl to a vector field you're going
to get some kind of function of x and y
but the fact that this is constant tells
us that when we look over at this fluid
flow the since in which curl the formula
for curl wants to say that rotation
happens around the center is just as
strong as it's supposed to happen over
here on the right
or anywhere on the plane for that matter
so for playing this and if you imagine
you know the paddle wheel in the center
evidently it would be rotating just as
quickly as the paddle on the right even
though it might i don't know to me that
feels a little unintuitive because the
one on the right i'm thinking okay you
know there's maybe there's a little bit
more torque on the right side than there
is on the left and that's kind of a
counter balancing act but the idea that
that's actually the same as the very
clear-cut i see the counter-clockwise
rotation with my eyes example in the
center does seem a little unusual
but i think it's important to understand
what else two-dimensional curl can look
like and what else this formula might be
representing
so with that i'll see you next video